when it comes to breast cancer which
affects nearly 4 million women black
women have the odds stacked against them
that's because they are 40 percent more
likely to die from the disease than any
other group the reasons are many denise
valdez explores why in our buddy check 8
report
[Music]
while black and white women get breast
cancer at about the same rates black
women are 40 percent more likely to die
from the disease and are also more
likely to be diagnosed before the age of
40 when annual screenings typically
start but it goes much deeper than that
dr joanna fulayan is an ob gyn in las
vegas she's confident there are at least
two main reasons for the disparity the
first black women's access to health
care lack of access to medicine meaning
they can't afford
medical care they don't have insurance
it's expensive to get a mammogram the
second and maybe even bigger obstacle a
mistrust of the medical profession to
let them know that
we
want to work with them
we are like them basically to teach them
that we are aware of what happened in
the past and we're going to make sure
that that does not happen again she's
referring to the documented experiments
on african americans in the days of
slavery these are things that occurred
but would never ever happen again in
this day and age black women tend to
receive a later diagnosis often with
more aggressive types of breast cancers
so annual screenings are vital but she
also urges her patients to know their
body i think that women should
definitely concentrate on
get doing their self breast exams
i think they should do it every month i
think they should do it a week after
their menses dr felian knows firsthand
the importance of early detection and
treatment she's a breast cancer survivor
herself
for buddy check denise valdez live local
now